[Music]
in nympho monk news
I heard about this nympho monk there's a
monk that'd be [ __ ] news so he'd be
[ __ ] all the other monks at the Newton
monastery we're gonna find out okay
cabinet a submitted by frozen water ice
a Buddhist monk was arrested for having
a drug-fueled sex parties in his temple
yes finally some [ __ ] Asian scandal
look I'm tired of hearing all these I
mean sex scandal cuz you guys have a lot
of scandals sex scandals yeah we have
scandals that are like Chinese people
put like mercury in fish to make it way
yeah scandal so there's like you make
them look a little bit sexy and risque
you know I don't know if this is a look
you're going for you do about this yeah
I was scrolling in a sign I was like why
because it was so rare to see I was just
like wow that's true because you don't
want that kind of sex scandal like like
it's like Catholic priests be touching
little boys you want to see like Buddha
smut and they're like you have nerve
no no no yeah monk master Chi hung oh
yes secretary Betty is hung Chinese
young Buddhist Association oh that young
Buddha man so he's 29 years old this was
a master to swing on he started since he
was 14
oh good about you oh yeah my mom wanted
me to be a month you you would've
definitely [ __ ] up a temple do you
guys know one huh you guys are not one
he shared I didn't have time I'm sorry
it came out before my hand winner all
right so this guy he was found with 19
grams of f of amphetamines smoking pipes
condoms anal relaxants
erection medication and a bottle of holy
water that was Lube what do you mean
anal relax
I don't know Buddhist people had holy
water then this fool is all freaked out
as holy water
also they found two USB drives that
contain over 200 gigabytes of porn just
a lot male-on-male sex videos that were
made and made my and starring him he's
dude you're passing it around the temple
no so he's a [ __ ] porn star - well
like he made his own videos that's what
I'm saying is he [ __ ] all the other
monks in the monastery in the boys oh I
don't know
changes the story a little bit I mean it
still [ __ ] up it still he got kicked
out from a previous temple because they
like for some behavior and stuff but
then when he when he went to a new
temple soon after that can you just be a
[ __ ] civilian like you can do all
this but like just move yourself from it
yeah but then he doesn't have shelter
and stuff though oh yeah like the free
food yeah okay so this whole is saying
like like pretty much saying like hey
Gramps you want some of this Gramps
grandpa are you tired too old man and
then he's like oh you're making me so
scared you know like uh like when you're
like like on CUNY talk like and you're
like in Korean like being like all cute
so he's been a cute little dude with
like an old [ __ ] man do Wendon the
[ __ ] didn't [ __ ] one of the fun
brothers become a mom this was nasty
he's like oh [ __ ]
okay looks like Daniel you know this
[ __ ] from his nose yeah another
dude he's getting a [ __ ] while he's
smoking his buddies I don't know I just
see his hand moving dude why let's just
skip this one this one's too much next
article please Darby Chinese news
Chinese in the free hardcore look at how
much they're showing deficient I don't
know why there's no censorship in that
dude there really wasn't you know what
that was it was just a regular video
with me doing this just squinting my
eyes you can still see everything yeah
that was worse than Japanese porn like a
blur job yeah so this was published by
the Taiwanese news outlet this homes
gonna get kicked out of I hope so like
please it's actually been arrested but
he was released on bail of about two
three thousand dollars he was charged
with violating the narcotics hazard
Prevention Act
how do you even get math in [ __ ]
China made that [ __ ] dude can you
imagine like this fool like you just
hired this fool to come bless her house
you know for like China like a lot
Chinese culture I'll do that like oh
come press my wedding bless my house and
you're like [ __ ] the floor that blessed
my house is a [ __ ] freak definitely
just got done sucking some old dick yeah
he's [ __ ] sprained his come holy
water but you gotta think about it Doug
there's multiple dudes that he's a
plaything to yeah what if there's a big
monk conspiracy because I've heard
rumors that homosexual activity and
things like that
in monasteries is it's not like this
isn't the first time it happened like it
happens a lot I'm sure
you know but the drug-filled orgies with
monk dudes that's why my first Bing was
like yeah is he [ __ ] the other monks
in the monastery yeah he had that loop
yeah but I know I in holy water
oh that's just disturbing I know why so
they could bless their [ __ ] dick
afterwards it's like you just leave that
the monster just become a civilian
didn't evolve to to that religion or vow
I said vouch Oh cuz I just thought made
last night that's why I she's nasty dude
but yeah man just don't don't be a monk
and do that if you want to do that you
could do that just do it on your this
just strikes a weird core to me because
when I was a kid I suspend every spring
break at a monastery so I lived with a
bunch of dudes and to me Oh super
innocent right like they would make me
noodles and all and stuff like that I
would help repaint different parts of
the temple specifically the one in
Hacienda but knowing that there's a
chance that [ __ ] like this was going on
and like the other room it would say it
freaks me though as a human being or a
bot for a living person in this world to
be [ __ ] doing - baby talk to a
grandpa while he's [ __ ] with loop I
smoking meth that's a sketch that's
entirely Bigham [ __ ] dude would you
allow here to come here would you allow
the monk to come here as a guest
hell yeah asking questions that's what
my question is what if this guy was
groomed to do this and it's just
breaking out a lot of kids join
monasteries at a very early age
oh yeah so he'd join and he leave the
house and they just lived there yeah so
you join when he was 14 and then he was
under this other master and then they're
saying that when that master died that
that's when he started doing all this
crazy like sex finally it's about pie
and [ __ ] man the way this all leaked was
he had a dated former lover who was also
a month
and so he downloaded all those clips and
then he sent it which belonged to
another one of his boyfriends see
they're all dating each other in there
yeah when like he sent it to temple
authorities and all this surface
that's so weird this room must smell so
bad dude like meth income a little bit
of incense probably and it's a little
bit of that [ __ ] five-spice in their
days and you rely on these guys to
perform exorcisms and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
clean out your house they bring the
filth in your house dude yeah they're
bringing that negative [ __ ] yeah that
matters evil drug man mr. hyung I don't
mean to be disrespectful but you smell
like um I think my god you smell like a
lot of cumin damn dude that's gross it's
not common in senses like huge news
that's why I never like trust like
people all people right but then when
people get titles and like religion dude
religions are like like they're all of a
sudden like a little bit better or a
little bit untouchable yeah [ __ ] that
dude I'm extra skeptical suspect very
dude because it's there in a position
where they can easily [ __ ] people over I
mean look at a Catholic priests perfect
example look at that [ __ ] passes that
came out on a cable Mon do the cable
pack
they fly and zip line cable pastor [ __ ]
that guy huh [ __ ] that man
don't give your [ __ ] trust to anybody
you don't really really know you should
talk to your mom about this I sure I'm
actually really interested cuz I either
she's gonna defend it hella hard and say
like yeah I'm not defend him but say
like he didn't lie this never happens
this is the one person cuz if this
happens here I'm sure it happens all
over the place you know so either that
or she might be like oh this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] crazy and I'm a freak - I'll
[ __ ] love meth I don't know I'm just
throwing out that one I was often Zopa
Thai friend was saying that there was a
scandal at the time monastery back in a
day where they were taking the offering
money and then getting like the monks
were getting hookers and drugs and
partying and like so this happens you
know like I think with power
and influence and all that stuff it's
it's easily corruptible easily and you
get a bunch of guys and you don't let
them come over 30 years yeah they're
gonna go crazy I don't get that part
like why does it have to be like why
that well I don't know for Catholicism
yeah why celibacy all of them are like
solid they're supposed to be right I
think that's what it's causing them to
do all this crazy [ __ ] like it's against
human nature a little bit yeah just let
him take off a little bit and you have
to let him do that I think it's like
you're supposed to be above that and let
go of human needs I mean human emotion
makes us human exactly that's why
sometimes religion pushes us against thy
being human I would definitely not take
advice from a dude that hasn't came at
all clearly right smart after I come you
have no [ __ ] oh yeah dude
you're like that [ __ ] snapchat filter
with all the equations in [ __ ] exact
right after you come all the equations
come out I do my taxes in ten minutes
dude that's how fast it is you like the
matrix [ __ ] numbers it only lasts for
like 60 seconds though how do you cure
cancer well simple there's a formula up
card yeah you think two months saying
well simple yeah
[Music]
Oh